[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who's getting
as many miles out of this movie as I can
and this video we're breaking down Earth
42 from Spider-Man across the
spider-verse the movie ends with a big
twist and in it we realize that Miles
has actually been taken to an earth
unlike a Zone where things are slightly
off it's basically like that episode of
Sliders where they think they've finally
made it home but then one of them
realizes the gate doesn't Creak like it
used to so so they leave because it's
just not the same morons but we'll not
get into that and instead throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down what happened on Earth 42 and also
all the clues that teased that there was
a Twist coming now this entire thing was
actually set up all the way back in the
first film which we pointed out on our
into the spider-verse breakdown
we can actually see that miles's Spider
Sense initially is green and purple
before it changes to blue and red
Aaron's colors are actually green and
purple but the fact that Miles changes
shows that he's no longer going to be
led potentially to a life of crime by
his uncle and he will instead follow in
the footsteps of Peter hate hearing
myself back I know but I love how the
film builds upon that as we know the
main miles we follow would have likely
have become the prowler had the spider
not intervened that movie is actually
filled with a ton of nods to the number
42 and it appears throughout the entire
film this includes Mars's winning
lottery ball at the start which gets him
a place at Visions Academy the back of
the spider and we see the number 42 on
the ground when miles fails his first
jump his basketball hoodie in this film
has 42 on it and there's these constant
ties throughout the entire film in the
first movie there was actually a major
clue that the spider was from an
alternate universe as we saw glitching
out just like the other spider peeps did
they show that this Earth was in its
home however it's still somewhat carried
the destiny that it was was always
supposed to have you see this spider
comes from an alternate reality where
Miles was supposed to be the sole
Spider-Man of that Universe this spider
was supposed to be part of that Cannon
and thus when it arrived on miles's
Earth it immediately sort him out and
what that does is that it gives that
Universe to Spider-Man in both miles and
the Chris Pine version that we made at
the start but that Earth 42 is now
without theirs and thus it ends up going
down a darker path in this film we meet
loads of different ones from across the
Multiverse and basically every reality
is supposed to have its own Spider-Man
or Spider-Woman doesn't matter what the
race gender or ages or even species and
we meet several different people who all
end up becoming their universes
Spider-Man whilst the traditional one
and Peter Parker never comes to be this
is of course seen in Gwen's world where
she dons the mantle or as Peter doesn't
therefore on miles's Earth the Chris
Pine version was meant to be the main
one and miles would just go on to likely
become the prowler now on Earth 42 they
didn't have that Chris Pine Vision or
well any other vision and that's why the
alternate Rio has no idea who Spider-Man
is instead miles 42 is gonna become this
universe's protector but the
intervention of Jonathan on changed
absolutely everything now when this
sputner writes origin story we actually
see that there's a classroom with a
spider in it behind a glass case this is
what the spot pulled across and this was
the one that would have bitten Prowler
miles we see how close it almost got as
well as in the classroom you can catch
miles 42 with his back turn and this has
made Crystal Clear due to the character
having the braids that we see him
wearing later on and that spider then
bid our miles and due to it having DNA
from Earth body 2 it was forever
intrinsically linked with this reality
as for Earth 42 this is a major part of
the movie that actually has a lot going
on with it in terms of spelling out
what's happening on that Earth firstly
when miles crash lands we can see that
the sky is light with the color green
which is of course the prowler's colors
in the main Universe ryo's eyes are
brown whereas here they appear green and
Miles even dance a green and purple code
after picking them up from the floor in
the prowler's room this is what kind of
gave it away for me when I was watching
the movie as they heavily lean into
those classic Prowler colors now later
on in the scene we hear about the
Sinister Six cartel who are clearly
running crime in this universe's
Manhattan when miles first lands we see
a billboard with the number six on it
and throughout the landscape there's
several other ones that could point out
which super villains are members just
before miles arrives at Times Square we
see a big sign with the word vulture
written on it and when he hits a
location there's another name too just
below the Sony sign we can see the name
Electro and this is advertising 2G phone
reception which it might be a downgrade
yeah but at least people aren't running
wild with 5G covered conspiracy theories
and I remember who you did it I remember
seeing those Facebook posts mate I seen
you posting that I don't I won't forget
2020. and we also see a sign where Aaron
takes miles to the roof and we can see a
building that looks like it has the word
hammer on it potentially this is teasing
Hammerhead and there's also a sign that
appears to say scorpion there's also a
bit where we can catch the name Sandman
as well so that leaves one slot left
which I'm guessing is the prowler I do
have a feeling that the cartel may
appear in the next film and that they're
laying breadcrumbs here for a big
villain team up come the next movie now
as a problem is Universe I want to first
break down exactly what's going on with
him and then go into what's being said
by one of the actors firstly though if
you're enjoying the video then please
smash that like button like Aaron
smashed that punching bag and make sure
you subscribe for a big breakdown and
review of The Flash coming really soon
now we learn that in this universe
miles's father Jefferson was killed due
to a Canon event still playing out
exactly the same as how would have
without the spider's intervention
whether miles had powers or not it
wouldn't have changed this and this
thing is continued as normal this is
something that we've seen in other
Spider-Man stories and in the
PlayStation 4 game miles's dad was also
killed too in the ultimate human this it
was actually his mother Rio who died but
she was brought back as a gift after the
events of Secret Wars when the timeline
was restructured either way miles's Dad
Jefferson dying has left a big hole in
his life because of this Mars has been
raised by his mother and uncle Aaron the
latter of which could only help the
family through nefarious means in that
first movie when we met miles he was
hanging out with Aaron a lot and he's
clearly continued on this path and been
taken him by his influence this is what
made him become the prowler and it's
also what's kept Aaron alive you see in
that first film aaroni died because Mars
became Spider-Man he was tasked by the
Kingpin to hunt him down and this is
what eventually got him killed so Miles
not becoming Spider-Man doesn't allow
that to happen and instead we have the
death of Jefferson playing out whereas
Aaron doesn't pass away we see Prowler
miles has become a big name in this
crime ridden universe and miles is
pulled into it all through a case of
mistaken identity now the prowler and
the comics originally started off as a
villain but he eventually became famous
sort of anti-hero once all the
connections to miles was set up this is
also reflected in the Miles Morales game
in which he kind of helped guide you at
some point now why I'm telling you this
is because some people have dropped a
few time on the scene and have said that
Prowler miles might actually become a
good guy that could be the case and
potentially at the end of beyond the
spider verse we'll see him becoming the
protector of f42 after all it's overrun
with criminals and prowl miles May
return after being swayed by our mouths
showing there's a different way I
actually have a theory time that Aaron
will take the hit for Jefferson and
miles's universe and that he'll die
instead in order to save the brother
that he never could I also suspect that
these two are gonna meet and that
they'll finally get to say all the
things that they wanted to when you
think about it Jefferson never really
got to say goodbye to his brother in
that first film and I'm guessing a
similar thing happened here with Aaron
they never got to patch things up and I
think the third film will allow them to
say the things they never got to say in
their respective Earths now there is
also the potential at prowl miles may
become a nemesis to this one and this
was actually teased up by shimik mura
during a recent interview my other
Genesis would be somebody who was like
really type A and really strict with all
the rules and everything had to be done
a certain way oh I would just hate that
person sounds like you have beef with
20.99 you know I would say I would have
to say the same that would that would
drive me nuts I would hate that person
too my real arch nemesis might be myself
in another dimension and with different
morals someone that is me but every
decision I would make they make the
opposite decision and they're but
they're just as powerful or strong or
talented or whatever as me
Martin spoiled the entire thing but I
think it's important to acknowledge at
least how he perceives the other miles
one thing that you might not have
noticed as well is that problem miles is
actually played by a completely
different voice actor this is done by
Gerald Jerome and it allows him to lean
more into his Puerto Rican side due to
his dad not being around miles here
pronounces Morales more like he's
speaking Spanish and I love this little
soul change to differentiate the
universes they still have their
similarities though and miles is
strapped to a punching bag just like how
Pita B was in that first film whether he
wants to help miles or not is another
thing entirely but I think the Aaron is
likely gonna be the key here as miles
says there's still good in him and he
too has just learned that his brother's
alive in another reality however this
being said to the backdrop of Heart of
the City might show that there ain't no
love between them now the brother
himself is also likely going to be
making a big appearance in the MCU very
shortly Donald Glover PS is a
live-action version of him in the film
and we actually have some updates on
what's happening with this now you might
have heard a while back that Sony were
developing a Hypno Hustler project that
was due to have Donald Glover as the
lead producer on it this would mean that
he could potentially be the actor too
however this has now reportedly been
scrapped that he can play the prowler in
the MCU now though he was pretty low
level during the events of homecoming we
of course know that there's a big
five-year time Jump In which anything
could have happened I'd love to learn
that Aaron had actually become the
prowler during this time and it would
all just tie things together and make
for some really good fan service anyway
I won't go into that because I've gone
over that Easter egg in-depth hundreds
and hundreds of times already but there
is a lot of things that if you're a fan
and you know how it's played out that's
gonna make that incredible anyway
there's lots of things to talk about
here and I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and where you think that
they're gonna take things with parallel
miles if you want to support the channel
for as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you you'll get early access
to videos every week last week we
dropped the Termini the video early why
the scene in Spider-Man across the
spider versus perfect early and the
podcast episode as well and I'm just
trying to give members that extra
content to thank them for all their
support basically really means a lot and
if you want to buy some merch as well we
also have a store over at xerodation.com
which sells lots of nerdy inspired merch
who just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction and spy t-shirt as
well so if you want to head over there
and help us out then the links in the
description now if you want something
else to watch then definitely check out
our video going over why all the
multiverses across the Marvel Universe
are in fact dying there's lots of Clues
there that this is leading to a big
thing playing out and yeah I'll not
spoil it but yeah you want to learn more
go over there after this by the way huge
thank you for clicking the video I've
been Paul you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace